ccsd will meet again in january 2021 to
decide
when to return students to campus but
even with campuses close to students the
nursing staff is there working hard
kirsten joyce joining us live in studio
to show us the many steps
that they're taking to prepare for kids
eventual return to school
well brian there are many new situations
that each school nurse is tackling
and they're getting very creative with
having to allocate an area at school for
those who get sick
trying to have everything in place
because we can technically go back to
school
in person at any time anna castle is the
school nurse for nearly 1300 high school
students at a-tech advanced technologies
academy
and 800 students at tom williams
elementary i do miss seeing my kids but
and i've i've called some of their
parents and talk
and tell them to say hi and they've been
doing okay
during the past nine months she's been
doing a combination of both in-person
and google meets
conducting health assessments on campus
for special education students
and working to connect with parents
whose students need medical procedures
in addition to her many regular duties
there are new procedures she's
implemented due to coven 19.
we're doing a lot of contact tracing
trainings so that you know when we do go
back to school we
we are well versed on how we're going to
keep track of our students
and you know to keep them safe part of
the new protocol involves designating a
space as an isolation area
finding a room at each school to convert
one that ideally has running water and a
bathroom
like at atec my principal and i we
walked
the campus and he gave me a couple
options
so we decided to convert what is now the
college and career center
um into our isolation room and the
reason we need a separate room
versus our health office is because our
health office needs to stay
as the whale area kind of like when you
go to the pediatrician
you have the wet will area in the sick
area
and you know all those medical consent
forms you fill out for your child before
they return to school while nurses are
busy working to get all those
electrically
electronically signed by parents before
that time